[Música]
el gobierno del presidente del
salvadoreño bukele ha recibido críticas
internacionales por las presuntas
violaciones a los derechos humanos
durante el estado emergencia declararon
el país para intentar frenar la
violencia generada por las pandillas
según la directora para las américas de
human rigth watch tamara taraciuk este
régimen de excepción abre la puerta para
que se cometan graves violaciones a los
derechos humanos incluyendo a la niñez
en lugar de proteger a la población
tarasiuk se solidarizó con las familias
de las víctimas de la violencia así que
así como también las organizaciones
nacionales de derechos humanos y con los
periodistas que han sido acusados por el
presidente salvadoreño macbook l de ser
socios de los pandilleros para ello
entonces quiero saludar en este momento
a eduardo escobar él es el director de
acción ciudadana gracias a eduardo por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 un muy buen día para usted le
pregunto entonces cuál es la situación
de los derechos humanos en el salvador
sobre todo en las cárceles donde hay
hacinamiento y además donde el
presidente amenaza
y dejarlos sin ningún tipo de comida
bueno gracias por la invitación le
comento en este momento en el país para
la ciudadanía que no está detenida que
vivimos el día a día estamos en una
situación de alta exposición a vitalidad
es por parte del gobierno con estas
medidas que se han tomado y digo
expuestos a la arbitrariedad porque
estamos en un régimen de excepción donde
por ejemplo
una persona que sea detenida puede pasar
sin ser presentada a un juez envían de
investigación hasta 15 días sin conocer
su familia a dónde se encuentra sin
tener asistencia legal sin saber cuál es
la imputación que se le está haciendo de
algún delito entonces estamos ante esa
situación como ciudadanos que te digo lo
que tenemos libertad lo que estamos
fuera de las prisiones y los reos en
este caso se están viendo también
afectados con las medidas del gobierno
según lo ha dicho el presidente no están
recibiendo toda la alimentación de vida
parece que les han quitado las
colchonetas están restringidos de salir
de sus celdas entonces hay una situación
muy complicada que se está dando en este
momento a pesar de que el estado
salvadoreño había señalado que tenía
control de los territorios en el país
claro eduardo le pregunto entonces
ustedes como organizaciones defensores
de todos los derechos humanos como
reaccionan a esta amenaza de presidente
de dejar a los ruedos sin comida
nosotros como organización es sin duda
no estamos defendiendo a la criminalidad
no estamos apoyando a las pandillas lo
que nosotros hemos señalado es y lo que
queremos de las autoridades de seguridad
pública es que investiguen que detengan
que lleven a un juicio justo y se
sancione a los miembros de pandillas que
han cometido delitos eso es lo que
nosotros queremos no queremos que sigan
muriendo salvadoreños pero obviamente lo
que le exigimos al gobierno para
proteger a la ciudadanía honesta es que
todas estas medidas se hagan en el marco
de la ley eso es lo que le estamos
exigiendo porque hay detenciones
arbitrarias hay acciones arbitrales de
las fuerzas de seguridad eso afecta al
ciudadano honesto entonces combatan la
criminalidad tomen las medidas que sean
necesarias en el marco de la ley y la
constitución bajo la lógica de que el
estado va a respetar los derechos va a
aplicar justicia y no va a buscar
venganza porque ese es el la narrativa
que ha planteado el gobierno venganza y
lo ha llamado una guerra contra las
pandillas
pero es una venganza donde no cabe una
opinión y señales que se están
cometiendo irregularidades claro y eso
quería preguntar decir realmente el
ejecutivo de buque le podría oír y
pudiera escuchar lo que ustedes como
organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos humanos piden cuando se ha
demostrado un gobierno completamente
autoritario además de no respetar todos
los derechos civiles y los derechos
humanos tanto de las personas que están
en la calle digamos sin ningún tipo de
asociación con criminalidad y de los
detenidos que podría enfrentar entonces
el ejecutivo en materia de derechos
humanos qué consecuencias digamos
bueno internamente
obviamente si se dan algunas violaciones
que ya se han denunciado también y no
hay un mecanismo efectivo que
sancione al estado por violaciones a
derechos humanos y repare el daño no no
tenemos esa instancia no tenemos ese
recurso como ciudadanía salvadoreña para
frenar abusos y corregir abusos y
sancionar a los responsables no existe
esto al interno porque el presidente
tiene capturada la institucionalidad
entonces está en función de los
intereses del gobierno los intereses del
presidente la instituciones que deberían
de velar por el tema de derechos humanos
y lo segundo es que donde podría haber
alguna posibilidad de sanción para el
gobierno por violaciones a derechos
humanos es a nivel internacional es ante
la comisión interamericana a la corte
interamericana pero
tenemos un discurso de rechazo del
presidente de señalando de protección de
pandilleros a estas instancias entonces
si hay alguna denuncia por violación a
derechos humanos en estas instancias
regionales lo que probablemente va a
ocurrir es que el gobierno rechace esas
sanciones y ha hecho y el presidente
dijo que hay que pensar en salirse de
estos organismos que protegen a
criminales muy rápidamente tenemos a 30
segundos que está pasando con las
amenazas de bucle a la prensa
y reformaron el código penal y la prensa
si publica una nota donde haga alusión a
las pandillas y puede ser el periodista
sancionado con una pena de prisión de
hasta de 15 años es decir ya la prensa
tiene limitado con esta reforma informar
a la ciudadanía sobre la situación que
está pasando con las pandillas claro
bueno dar muchísimas gracias entonces
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 un gran abrazo
desde bogotá 2 saludos gracias buen día